[Music]
all right kids and that's how i defeated
the world's most dangerous villains with
only my two fists
[Music]
my desert eagle
[Music]
and two rocket launchers eat peace
[ __ ]
any questions have you met wonder woman
she did spend an entire party if and me
from across the room sick dude
dude i said effin
[Applause]
peacemaker i was hesitant to bring you
onto this team
but right now the world needs suddenly
[ __ ]
you're the only one i got
you know you don't have to call me
peacemaker you can call me chris just
because you're handsome doesn't mean
you're not a piece of [ __ ] you think i'm
handsome oh my god okay
this task force doesn't officially exist
you want to do this job
you can't [ __ ] ever
listen i can help you i'm stealing with
weapons in combat
[Music]
you don't have to shoot people after all
to kill them
right
[ __ ] game day [ __ ]
aren't you guys being a little
nonchalant about all this are you
insinuating there is a wrong time and a
right time to rock
[ __ ] yeah
you don't understand what we're up
against
we need every hand on deck is that an
eagle
a sidekick
dude we're saving the world
it's everything we've ever wanted
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
[Music]
how do you like that i like it i like it
a lot i don't give a [ __ ] what give it
all you got
hey
don't worry i'm not giving this guy
anything
uh maybe you could just give him a
little
hey sweet cheeks can you take my order
real quick seriously didn't chit chat
cheeks it's cosmic sweet cheeks is your
butt no it's not it is it's like calling
somebody i don't know sugar tits totally
inappropriate
jets are way too big to be sugar tits
sugar sets like smaller perky tits like
yours uh technically i think you may
have sugar tits too but somehow that
also feels inappropriate
[Music]
you